For memories to form,
three functions have to take place.
Acquiring - learning or experiencing
something new.
Consolidating - this is where
the memories become stable.
And finally, recall -
the ability to recall that
information in the future.
Can juggling really increase
brain activity?
German researchers divided
24 non-jugglers into two groups
and asked one group to practise
juggling for three months.
They found that those who didn’t
juggle showed no difference
in brain activity
over the test period.
But those who juggled, had an
increase in grey matter in two areas
of the hippocampus and neocortex,
parts of the brain involved in
memory, visual and motor activity.
The brain is like a muscle
and needs exercise.
To exercise your memory
you don’t necessarily have to learn
a new physical skill like juggling.
(Speaking Spanish)
A memory palace is where
you imagine a place
where you can store information.
Memory experts use this trick a lot
to remember number sequences
or even a whole deck of cards.
Let's say you have a simple list
of things you want to buy.
Step one:
Start at your door and go
anticlockwise around your room,
labelling each item
one to seven in order.
Step two:
In my room,
my bed is the first object.
So I would place the first item
I want to remember -
buying an apple, for example -
on my bed.
Step three:
Create a visual image
and exaggerate it in some way
to make it more memorable.
If the first item is an apple,
picture a big purple apple
crushing your bed.
Repeat the process until
every piece of information
is associated to an item
in your memory palace.
During sleep, your body rests,
although your brain is busily
processing information from
the day to form memories.
People who recall their dreams
improve their memory
and are more creative.
Try keeping a dream diary
of some sort.
Just a notebook and pen, so you can
write down or sketch
as much as you can remember
as soon as you wake up.
So there you have it. Acquiring,
consolidating, and finally recall.
Simple tips to improve your memory.